but I'm just a swingers party dude I
went I was in Lake of the Ozarks
Missouri and as we were doing a stand-up
gig I loved it there yeah it's beautiful
and they me and this dude pull up this
young brother who actually this guy went
to jail is in oh isn't jail right now
for murder hope he's listening uh he
might I don't if he gets do you guys get
go to jail do you guys play in jail I
think they can have access somehow they
know that's all the inmates praise God
Trump did that I bet you know you don't
really I mean got a little credit
commissary your sticky buns with some
fire in the kid there wita Trump said
I'm unleashing fighter in the kid in all
prisons across America that'd be dope to
turn Trump dude I bet in ten years you
and Trump could be doing a tag team
match somewhere so down but I'll back to
your boy who's in prison listening so
yeah so I pull it so me and this guys
are now on my second marker yeah
Springer yeah you know we here's what
happened we pull into this hotel and
this is the hotel we usually say that
we've been there before to do this gig
you know you do a one-nighter in Lake of
the Ozarks and you do the other two
nights in Columbia Missouri and we pull
in down there to Lake of the Ozarks we
walk up to the front desk of the hotel
we've been there before and they said
boys only girls only or boys and girls
only and I'm thinking like well [ __ ] you
know I think I'm just trying to get
these you know Ramada Rewards club
that's all I'm thinking you know I think
so boys own yeah I'm like what Honors
Program is this like is this you know
some sort of Lake of the Ozarks
yeah that's your point yeah so anyhow
dude they have bracelets with these
boxes and it was a swingers had rented
out the whole hotel all they're trying
to [ __ ] and they didn't even know we
were coming and the the hotel had forgot
that they had this this monthly deal
with the comedian's way to go yeah so we
show up and we don't have anywhere else
to go and so they let us stay there for
the weekend we couldn't compete in any
activities right which is like they got
all kind of sex games and you would see
just like these couples rolling in with
those like push cards like Lake of Ozark
I'm trying to be cool here this I
wouldn't say mmm it's not the most
beautiful oh it wasn't real hotties dude
and they had a couple of people brought
her brother and with him you see a
couple of white older white people the
young brother and you're like what is
this you can tell he was that hitter
brush yeah he's the cleanup oh he was
Albert Bell do you don't say it now
that's old skis Tony Gwynn Bravo he's a
Mark McGwire it was a lot of Rick
Sutcliffe sand a [ __ ] tendon that
Tony Gwynn you know and a lot of the
couple's look the same man and woman yes
so here cuts very similar haircuts yeah
and it was Midwesterners and they were
out of shape
Oh Walmart fans not a lot of shape yeah
this is one shape yes it's kind of a
general Shea melting yeah kind of mother
all melted yeah kind of like gravity's
buddy kind of say you know I went to
little Walmart there were used to going
on spring break my boy Paul Creighton
had a experience out of house there so
we go on the lake there and yeah it's
the best
and we went to Walmart to like pick up
beer and snacks and [ __ ] and I thought I
was in a different country yeah
beautiful guys people though oh yeah
beautiful dude
the probably don't probably don't wanna
do a swingers party there though well it
was crazy so we're there for the weekend
right and so we couldn't go to any
events we would go do our comedy and
Matt so if you decide to start [ __ ] dude
we would have been the best men and
best-looking men and women at that whole
event if we would have walked in any so
the crazy thing was there's like this
big huge bingo downstairs he had like 20
of those what's that hand bingo thing
where you put your hands oh you taught I
know you're talking about yeah yeah no
it's uh
where you touch different colors yeah
our city right hand blue left leg yellow
and that you know like the United
Nations be twister your feet and hands
yeah whispering whisper yeah kid it's
like yes but naked and we do that in
college do you really yeah
with who girl okay get a roommate with
three ladies a Oh dick blue blue big
mouth so you so they were doing that
downstairs but they had like twenty
boards all put together in this huge
conference room
and they had like 50 people playing just
[ __ ] priming the walls with come yes
buster nuts yeah it was uh I mean but
people would also be sitting there
having like a bowl of snot like Fritos
and like they had like a hot new yeah it
was just I mean it was almost like a
carnival but with you no more cry like
just hella crotch at it you know yeah
but then the crazy part was dick yeah
carnival it didn't even some of the
vaginas look like dicks that were just
kind of giving up god I don't want to be
there oh I don't know Leigh there's some
banger swear parties yes how he
invite-only and I heard it's just option
goes down Howie Mandel has a great story
where he performed it one he didn't know
and he showed up he said they some lady
met him outside and then they brought
him in through a garage door and next
you know he's performing everybody just
[ __ ] in this room and he had her
perform plays a ledger 50 what's the
point
listen some guys like hey do that do
that bit about the taxi cab you know but
why would you fire a comedian suing his
party I think just as I grow shut up
you're [ __ ] what are you talking about
up there aren't you the guy from America
gots talent some [ __ ] shut up yeah um
but the crazy part was the elevator we
came in push the elevator one night and
the doors open and it was this just [ __ ]
trolley bro and there's just people
[ __ ] in there and drinking cherry 7up
out of a two liter straight of charity
selling man it's good it's nice
dude I'm when it came out it changed
everything man it was so much more
powerful then now it's just like yeah
it's cuz it's overrated you joined the
10,000 club you know I'm saying yeah
like those guys who hit 10,000 homeruns
do you think they give a [ __ ] bout
homeruns anymore
probably not oh you told ya a lot you
talkin about life now yeah like
breathing them Cal Ripken now my dick
yeah yeah it's too much but it's a lot
for kids man but yeah we went to that
swingers thing and we that elevator
opened up and I just remember seeing
just this whole you know it was almost
like the
it was like you know that painting that
Michelangelo did were those two people
are naked touching each other in the air
whatever theme
yeah sixteenth chapel it was like that
but it was like just a bunch of just
people just just guts and everything was
a titty like everything in there look
like at a smelled like Mountain Dew read
yeah it definitely had that [ __ ] dick
after scent
Fritos up front and [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
bag dude I would through us at hide and
go sniff dude you think you get him one
thing and you get another you know I
want that I went to a swingers party on
accident in Denver's below we're we're
parted up top went below it said do not
enter me my friends like he was like
bumping down there
so we went down there and we realized
there's a swingers party because that a
sign on it had like rules but it was
like I'd say the ratios ten to one dudes
he got into girls not good not getting
what like the the seven girls that were
there in the seventy dudes I just felt
bad for him yeah girl let's get out of
here thank you tell their morale was not
hot yeah her self-esteem was not booming
well that's why you got to have like a
robert e lee type of guy in there you
got to have a straight-up william
wallace running up and down the you know
the live a them yeah to motivate these
chicks that are at us at a gangbang
yeah you i keep the morale high cuz if
reality hits ago what the [ __ ] am i
doing you don't need that yeah you need
to be passing out DSW that tony robbins
dick game going
i need that do dropping knowledge
hackers women joking you can do this
yeah man women who put up with a lot
dude you know they're putting up with a
lot out there so well guys just a bus
that not at those swinger things man
really well yeah you're waiting in line
and [ __ ] like you're waiting for a ride
or some [ __ ] you know like you like uber
for your dick really a thing yeah you
gotta wait man there's gonna be some
other dudes dropping some gifts off
before you get in there man before it's
your turn to get your five minutes of
fame what kind of shoes do you wear I
would wear those pool shoes I think you
know like this described aqua socks
oh dude nothing nothing makes a girl dry
up fast an aqua Sox terrible idea bro I
might wear Uggs and that
ah I wish some always keep my feet warm
- where are my Yeezy 750 football yeah
you're gonna be I can make it Boston nut
dude I'd have to get my butt waxed I
think bro that's my thing like I have so
much hair my butt like I walk if I'm
hooking up with a chick I'll walk out of
the room back which is good smell but
it's that bad it just makes it I'm
self-conscious about it you know why
don't you uh Brazilian wax it I'm just
scared of that man I met a girl and she
waxes people's balls - yeah they called
it V and B button balls oh it's actually
the most common practice for men is it I
used to date a girl who specialized in
that and she she was like man 60% of my
clients are men because they do the B &
B you want to come in I'm like what is
it she was balls in but they literally
do all that the taint than your booty
hole I either a girl try it once on the
inside my thigh hmm never again hurt I'd
rather get a tattoo on my [ __ ] face
oh it hurts so bad
I'd rather get that [ __ ] Nate stamp
if you if you ever hear you ass like if
I could braid your ass there yeah oh you
should probably get it removed you
couldn't break and gel it down though
like it sparked it to the side dude I
had an uncle in he had so much hair on
his neck he would gel it down for the
hurts cause he didn't want to shave it
off because it was his hair and it was
like a thing against God you joke down
the thigh huh oh he jealous whole neck
hair down you might want to gel the your
you guys had a duck tail right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]